it seems uh redundant to talk about the
crisis down on the border because the
border has been in a constant state of
crisis for decades but the overall
underlying crisis flares up occasionally
into what what may more technically be
described as i don't know a super duper
crisis and that's what we're facing
right now particularly down in southwest
texas in del rio where thousands of
illegal immigrants have set up an
expansive bustling
impoverished tent city of sorts this is
what the compassionate
quote unquote immigration policies of
the democrat party get you
they get you
shanty towns in the desert they get you
immigrant families living under a bridge
they get you a third world invasion
which ultimately harms both the invaded
and the invaders
they also get you slavery and sex
trafficking
they get you kids raped and killed by
human smugglers
this compassion brings all manner of
misery and death and suffering to
everyone touched by it on both sides of
the border because this compassion is
not compassion at all it is total abject
indifference
this is why defending the border
and defending it vigorously harshly
with force if necessary is not only the
most just and appropriate policy as it
is the basic duty of our government to
protect its borders and its people but
it's also the most the most truly
compassionate
if you're actually concerned with
minimizing human suffering to the
greatest possible extent
and we all should be concerned with that
then you'll make sure that immigrants
know that the trek across the desert
will be fruitless there's no need to
come
certainly don't send your children
don't risk their lives or your lives for
this it won't work
that's a message of compassion
compassion both to the would-be illegal
immigrant
or the would-be child who's going to be
smuggled across the border
and also to your own people who live in
a sovereign nation and deserve to have
that sovereignty preserved and defended
this is a conversation we should be
having when it comes to illegal
immigration
but the media is not interested in that
conversation so instead as always they
change the subject they are perpetually
on the lookout for false narratives to
help them do that and yesterday they
found a very convenient one images began
circulating online of border patrol
agents on horseback
apprehending immigrants as they
attempted to storm the border
there is of course nothing at all
strange about this border patrol agents
are supposed to patrol and defend the
border it's right there in the name
border patrol and considering they're
out in the desert it makes quite a lot
of sense for them to perform this duty
on horseback
you see cops in major cities on
horseback so
and sometimes that to me
seems a little silly but
on the border in the desert makes a lot
of sense
but the images of
white looking border patrol agents on
horseback
and i say white looking because in fact
many of these border patrol agents are
hispanic
but the image
of a white looking border patrol agent
on horseback rounding up mostly black
haitian immigrants and more on the
haitian part of this story in just a
minute presented an opportunity to media
propagandists that they simply couldn't
pass up so it began with a guy named
sawyer hackett who providentially
actually has the word hack in his name
and he posted two images of the mounted
border patrol agents along with this
caption caption is
border patrol is mounted on horseback
rounding up haitian refugees with whips
this is unfathomable cruelty towards
people fleeing disaster and political
ruin
the administration must stop this
and now pardon the pun we're off to the
races the news was trending across
social media border agents are using
whips against haitian refugees
every major media outlet published their
own headline
these days a narrative cements and
metastasizes within minutes seconds even
that's all it takes
now it used to take longer for a false
narrative that the media has always
perpetrated false narratives perpetuated
false narratives
but in the past it would take some
effort to get people to
believe it
um but now with the internet it just
takes a second
all across social media and the news
media people were breathlessly
condemning the evil officers who are
whipping and lassoing haitians down on
the border like some kind of old western
film
comparisons to slavery were made
the white house was asked about the
whips
and jen pasaki though admitting that she
doesn't know the context
still said that the images are
inappropriate and terrible and even
horrific listen i've seen some of the
footage i don't have the full context i
can't imagine what context would make
that appropriate but i don't have
additional details and certainly i don't
have additional context april i don't
think anyone seen that footage would
think it was acceptable or appropriate
thanks so much jen um i want to follow
up on the question about haitians and
and specifically these these photos that
are surfacing on border patrol agents
seemingly using whips and they said that
there's no context that it would be seen
as inappropriate so the question really
is why would this be happening under the
side administration is this going to
stop what would the pro i i wonder
sort of what are going to be the
consequences if what we're seeing is
what we're seeing i mean yamiche it's
all good questions we just saw this
footage um it's horrible to watch um i i
just have to get more information on it
again april i don't i don't have more
information on it i've also seen the
video i can't imagine what the scenario
is where that would be appropriate i'm
certainly not suggesting that but we've
just seen the footage short earlier this
morning
i know you said that you're still
assessing it but just to add if this is
what we see is it the president's stance
or the white house's stance that whoever
these border agents are using what seems
to be whips on migrants that they would
be fired or at least never be able to do
that again of course they should never
be able to do it again i don't know what
the circumstances would be it's
obviously horrific the footage i don't
have any more information on it so let
me venture to do that and we'll see if
there's more to convey
yes i have no idea what's actually going
on she says but whatever it is it's
definitely bad these men down on the
border who work for us and are doing the
job they were hired to do
are clearly guilty of horrific
atrocities i don't know anything about
the situation but i know enough to throw
our own people under the bus that's for
sure
the white house showing more of its
trademark moral courage with that
response
but is it true that the border patrol
agents were using whips well the first
answer is that it doesn't matter if it's
true the narrative is all that matters
the truth is irrelevant
to almost everyone who is propagating
this narrative
the second answer is that no of course
it isn't even remotely true city boy
sawyer was perhaps intentionally
uh misinterpreting the horse reigns for
a whip
that's what those ropes on the horse are
there they're reins
okay and uh if if you've ever seen
someone on horseback and you've wondered
how they managed to steer the horse in
the direction that they want the horse
to go this is how they do it
and that must have seemed like a pretty
pretty weird magic trick
if you didn't know about horse rains
they don't you they don't use animal
telepathy it turns out
they also don't jump on the horse and
say all right sparky take me wherever
you want to go
where are we going today
no they use these things called reins to
steer the animal in the preferred
direction
that's what those ropes are
but we know the left has long had
trouble dealing with ropes they they're
very scandalized by really a any rope in
any form they're scandalized first they
thought a garage door pull in a nascar
garage was it was a was a noose i mean
they thought a a rope hanging from there
for a like a tire swing in a park was a
noose
they thought a a cord
at a cracker barrel was a noose
and now they think horse rains are a
whip
they seem to think that every rope is
somehow sinister i can only imagine what
would happen to these people if they
ever went into i don't know an indoor
rock climbing facility
whips and nooses all over the place they
probably think about some kind of bdsm
dungeon
so a second thought they'd feel right at
home i guess
but all of this talk of whips and nooses
obscures another more important point
we are told that the immigrant horde
being whipped quote unquote down in del
rio are haitians
now haitians i hope i don't have to
remind you
are from haiti
haiti i also hope i don't have to remind
you is not in mexico
or even near mexico it is an island
nation thousands of miles away across
the sea
the media is talking about these people
as if they're fleeing haiti itself which
would mean
that they got in boats presumably
thousands at a time and sailed up the
gulf of mexico hundreds and hundreds of
miles docked somewhere on mexico's coast
and then walked through the desert
parallel to the u.s border only to then
convene around southwest texas and try
to enter there all at once
that makes no sense at all
there would have been many potential
ports of entry much closer and easier to
access i mean if you're taking a boat
from haiti and you want to get into the
u.s
how do you end up in del rio
so that doesn't make any sense
but that's the impression we're supposed
to have when they talk about well the
haiti they're fleeing political
persecution and so on and so
the implication is that they are fleeing
haiti
but again that doesn't make any sense if
you're fleeing haiti you're not going to
end up in del rio of all places
so why are they there and why isn't
anyone in the media asking this
why are we having to talk about horse
reigns instead of discussing the origin
and intentions of this mysterious mass
of haitians hanging out in del rio for
unknown reasons
now i don't have all the answers myself
i have the questions which is why i'm
asking them
but it does seem pretty clear that many
of these people probably all of them
are not coming from haiti at all
they were withstand a reason already in
central america somewhere
and probably had been there for years
now this makes it dubious to refer to
them as haitian refugees or haitian
asylum seekers
if a haitian man moves to guatemala
and lives there for five years
and then tries to enter the u.s
illegally is he a haitian refugee
seeking asylum at that point i mean in
one sense
technically he's still haitian of course
but
the term gives a misleading impression
also why would we grant him asylum here
when he's already been living in another
country
he wants asylum from haiti right
well he was in guatemala why can't he
stay there
and if he's leaving from there he's like
he's got to cross other countries to get
to our country
but whatever we call
uh these people
whether haitian asylum seekers or just
illegal immigrants i tend to favor the
latter term
the question then becomes
and if they are leaving central america
why are they all leaving central america
and coming here now
why now why all at once
how do they all get there
why at that spot
these are valid questions i believe
questions worth asking
that again should be the first question
anyone in the media asks if they're
sitting at a press conference and being
told about a a tent city of haitian
immigrants
in del rio everyone should say wait what
haitian immigrants why
nobody even asks it nobody
well the media you know because they
don't want to talk about that
that's not a question they want to ask
because it's not it's not an answer they
want to be given
they'd rather talk about imaginary whips
and scary guys on horseback
they'd rather talk about anything but
the real point
as always
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated